so you might notice we've got another
pump in town this is Coco you might have
met him before
we're about to go to the thirsty problem
because Unruh turning my red eyes on I
want to buy a t-shirt today okay where's
your VA LL we had to separate the pups
because maddie is definitely not into
the energetic nature of Coco he's still
a puppy he's about six muscles
that's that I'm having a fun day with
two dogs we took some naps shot some
videos and now me and Jenna are gonna go
to know real quick because I'm heading
to New York tomorrow no this is you've
got the pups all by yourself all right I
get the phones packed up phones one
phone one case I'm adding we'll do it
fast okay so look at this the new iOS
10.3 carplay update they have these
little tabs you can be like in Spotify
and then like go do something else any
believer listen to Sam hunt I listen to
mold a kinnor hello we're driving to the
Apple store to return my phone I'm gonna
get a new case today all right okay we
got a hurry better hurry that's gonna be
closing and I got to go on the pack we
don't like show he's a dog for very long
the last time that I came down these
steps I was on my way to the Apple Store
and it was super early to get this home
that I currently have my backpack hey
guys missed a video that I flipped it I
was talking about the reason which I
wanted to return it was clearly it's
plain and simple I don't like to call a
read since I felt really bad about
returning a phone it was technically for
charity I am just gonna donate the full
amount of the phone that I paid for it
directly to the red foundation they'll
actually be getting a hundred percent of
my donation instead of I don't know like
a dollar - yeah from the red eyes alone
trying out a new lens today if a 16 to
70 so I've got a little bit more of a
zoom let me know what you guys think
okay what it's not that cold outside you
wear your winter jacket okay you and me
you like it yeah
please
picking up
into people
you can't do that
the transaction is complete Jen we did
it yeah but how about that riveting
footage I can't I don't know I haven't
seen it yet
oh you will do you think we'll supposed
to get out early what
give it like why would you want to have
a shirt that says I've got a toast on it
really look at you in a frog-leg oh my
goodness he's so cute yes he's a sweet
smile he pictures hair honey
all right a whole body so we're jumping
forward in time this clip that you're
seeing now is after I close to the red
iPhone video after I returned the video
after I got back from New York but I had
to apparently prove that number one I
bought the iPhone that I returned it and
that I donated to red because I was
reading the comments and people were
calling me the absolute worst things
ever I was like I basically am giving
money to charity
and you still are saying the most
hateful things ever honestly it's still
surprising to this day 11 years of being
on YouTube and even longer of being on
the Internet the people are so cruel it
surprised still surprise surprises me
every time it is actually quite
surprising they said that I should have
gave it away but the reason that people
the people of reason if people give Ivo
the way is to get subscribers that's not
a secret I've done giveaways so that I
can get likes and follows that's why
that's why people do it not that I don't
want to give you guys a phone but this
is a phone for charity I just thought
it's beyond me I'm beside myself right
now
here's my receipt here's the donation
receipt end of story
let's move on to this vlog I don't know
what we're doing next in this video I
think I belong to youtubers reaction why
here you win yes the timeline is skewed
good luck with the dogs Jen
I am heading off to youtubers react well
I haven't home show and so long since
we're excited to to be back and react
get my items ready
[Music]
look at this Benny just said back to the
original Gameboy hi how are you hi visa
I'm Justine this is exciting I haven't
been on in so long how are you I'm so
excited thanks for having me back thanks
for being back you were on the very
first episode of youtubers react there's
been over 100 now but you are there in
the beginning looking like world like
you talked about a bar all we have is a
day apart from each other some wait I
forgot the video I was doing and someone
said wow that you should be elders
reacted like what that's not accessible
thank you say to Justine I don't know
what it was it was a really funny video
but I was very confused about some piece
of technology and yep elders reacts here
I come but yeah I'm so excited
everything looks great this is cool
ok guys we'll see later bye we've got
pigeon oh my gosh hey let's montage
[Music]
abandoned montage others copy written
music and fountain though audio is not
actually we're going droning today I
just got back from shooting the fine
brothers Burbank to the west side on a
Sunday it's a really awful things so
much traffic what we're here waiting for
Nathan
then we're going to fly drones after we
eat they remembered us for my birthday
brunch he was like so you guys burn your
switches today only Jennifer on her
[Music]
[Applause]
you gotta get it afar then he is like it
like it or not there is a moment before
and now you make it but I already this
another exciting and you guys are now
officially drone certified part 107
certifying congratulations so for
anybody who isn't certified what tips do
you have for them because it's a big
step I mean we we went with UAV coach
and UAV coach comm reinterred bucks
they have video lectures they make it
super super easy so we watch all the
video lectures at the end of each video
lecture you take a 15 question quiz all
the questions they ask are pretty close
to what the government will actually ask
you when you get certified so we went to
their course we showed up we both pass
with flying colors and all we did was
exactly what they told us to but today
you guys are certified and we're being
safe and everything is awesome so let's
looks like the flooring all right oh I
can't wait to see the footage I mean
fire will you guys give it to movies you
have your laptop with you no I brought
the Kadri
[Music]
you could
though that you could understand I
cannot tell you how it felt
can't believe that I thought we were in
doubt but you would displace shooting
everything you could do happening
you did your best to make me sure I got
these today
no guys like you really finally know why
I
[Music]
this is the best event going I love it I
chose it far more terrible I just left
Louise with one and my voice is gone I'm
feeling so loud Rinku in love with music
you got a super cute little box I will
do an unboxing as soon as I get home I'm
to open Lily's box this is so exciting
what's in here
oh my goodness these are so so cute look
at this she's got her boss lipstick
which is absolutely beautiful I don't
usually wear lipstick and I've actually
wore it a few times and it stays on for
so long that you just actually don't
feel like you're wearing lipstick it is
so long lasting a little hashtag mug
look at these dogs yo back up you can
write your own hashtag on it this cup
comes with a pen and you can write the
hashtag on it whatever you want is a
clue word oh no is this what I think it
is yes it is behind it boss Nutella hide
it oh my goodness I'm gonna link in
description we guys can check out her
book and yeah that's it for this segment
of the vlog there may be more this could
potentially be the end of the video I
really don't even know
I'm going to New York for a day how many
clothes ready you don't even see my
electronics bag yet right here is I love
to have a smaller backpack to take on
the go when I get to my destination but
I need to put the backpack inside of the
backpack because I have nowhere else to
put it you can only have to carry on now
clean my office when I get back that's
what I'll do oh gosh hi Coco you being
good boy over here you see if you were
scratching for air I didn't take care of
the pups I'm off I'll see you in bed
oh I'll see you in one day to be
students okay today see you later I'm a
demon and miss you and you're going to
get a haircut on Thursday here for it
and usually in the morning over here at
LAX the service line is so long
usually you can wait in line for like an
hour and you
[Music]
this place is a madhouse I'm not really
sure why I mean usually lax is pretty
crazy but even though that Starbucks
line was along at all guess what it took
almost 40 minutes to get this all right
well I'm just going to sit here between
these trash cans because basically the
best option and I can find my board in
like 35 minutes
well I don't have to actually check a
bag everything goes so quickly and so
smoothly usually
[Music]
it's raining and it's cold welcome to
New York you knew you're making me
shiver he's not like you don't watch
traveling is exhausting and let me tell
you about this slight first of all my
chopped episode aired it tonight and it
was crazy because I believe landed I
stood up I was about to get off the
flight and I look over and this woman
was watching chopped and I was watching
her watch chopped watch me get chopped
either way it was by far one of the most
incredible things that I've ever done I
had so much fun on set and it was so
cool but it was a little bit difficult
because I was definitely competing
against people who actually cook are
trained chef - at the culinary school
and well I tried I mean I tried my best
but sometimes your best isn't actually
the best so really all you can do is try
your best and hope that it might be the
best and if it's not the best then you
got to work on being the best and if and
if you think you're never going to be
the best and maybe it's just best to do
something else I'm gonna stick to what
I'm good at I was just hoping that I'd
make it to the dessert round because I
wanted to make ice cream I've been
repairing some recipes and one of the
hardest parts is you know what I'm
cooking I'm looking at recipes I don't
know how to just make things so in
preparation for being on the show I did
actually a bunch of research I watched a
ton of YouTube videos about how to break
down a whole chicken if that was
something that I was presented with I
memorized cake recipes in case I made it
to the dessert round so I actually did
do some prep for this episode and
unfortunately if you watched it you guys
know that I got chopped the first
appetizer round
and non sunt energy vibration
approaching Comanches I think the cheese
maybe one day I can go back and
hopefully my cooking skills have
improved in other news I beat Ganon
I was playing Zelda on the flight and
let me tell you what this witch has
motion controls so I mean how do I even
explain this to you I gotta give you the
visual I mean like I kind of did but
there were some hearts they got super
intense and I wasn't really paying
attention to anything else except my
antenna switch so I'm going like this I
have my water sitting next to me and
then at one point I like hit it there
just like flew everywhere thankfully it
was in a bottle oh wow I just saw
something I need to show you do you guys
know what this is or what this looks
like that looks exactly like my computer
like valve looks like the trashcan Mack
but it's actually a trashcan think about
that for a second put that in your mind
and think about it I gotta try to tweet
that anyway I think that's it for this
vlog I think I'm gonna open up my note
what is my note say
the fella welcome home let me off this
many mean do to make your stay more
enjoyable I'm pretty I'm pretty good
right now
definitely your sleep sorry I'll see you
tomorrow right Apple in total has
donated 130 million dollars to the red
foundation the entire charity has raised
465 million which makes alpha one of
their leading donors now I have no idea
what the specifics are of percentages of
the iPhone sales or cases or how that
all works technically this phone is for
charity and I don't know how